what are five tips that you guys can
give our audience for how they can nail
it this holiday season okay one get a
caterer choose a bunch of is three leave
the kids at home five you know just
enjoy your family course family is very
important for the holidays but you know
what if you bake if you cook just have
fun in the kitchen at the end of the day
it doesn't matter you mess it up you can
always order out so just have fun in the
kitchen the booth helps nailed its
Nicole Byer and Jacques Torres serving
up tips and tricks on nailing it and
failing it this holiday season at a
pop-up event for the Netflix show in
Hollywood that's not a good sign that
blew my wig back nothing is more
stressful than a holiday fail so tell me
about one time you guys failed the
holidays I remember you not for leaving
I all my holidays I'm doing stuff so of
course sometime you messed up something
but at the end of the day it doesn't
look perfect it's okay it's the holidays
your family not going to roast you for
that you know I tried to make jock
mac and cheese when we were filming and
it turned out so poorly but I was like I
can't bring this to this man it wasn't
good but I promise you if she bring it I
will tell Nicole this is this you you
would have lied just to make you feel
good and I mean that's all I want in
life a man to lie to me to make me feel
good obviously the New Year's coming up
- so how do you know if you nailed it in
2018 I think people would tell you
they'd be like girl look at you you did
it and if nobody says those exact words
to you you didn't do so good no then
hashtag for them usually we are pretty
hard on ourselves so I don't know if I
really really ever tell myself yeah I
nailed it at the end of the day we have
to try to be happy
shy calls and we do have an a third
person here today you guys are gonna be
so excited
it's like a real episode of Neil bit I
love this I love our big happy TV show
family - what did you know when you
started working on the show that you
were gonna end up being like kind of a
third star no no how did this happen
they had no idea how to bring in the
they didn't have an idea to bring in the
trophy for the first episode so they
said why don't you do it for the first
time you'll figure something else that
later and then it became a it became a
thing I honestly thought that they were
just gonna cut me out of the entire
first season but they did not he is and
I've heard that people slide into your
DMS what's the weirdest thing anyone has
ever said to you it's not safe on to say
I don't think I can say it I'm like how
often are people slightly not not a lot
this it's not like I'm getting like
bombarded or anything I've just gotten a
few funny ones but like I'd shown the
wife we have a chuckle about it I love
it he's married guys lay off him
[Music]